salut roman ça va oui super à la pour
une fois ça fait plaisir à ya quand même
un truc et iphone os 4 ah je vois tu te
demandes si tu peux lui donner des
conseils aux entrées comme ça non je me
demande pourquoi il m'a pas proposé de
m'en donner un peu attends ta truc c'est
quoi le cholestérol une console de jeux
[Musique]
le cholestérol c'est un peu comme les
crêtes de coq tout le monde connaît le
nom tout le monde connaît quelqu'un
qu'on a même sans être forcément au
courant mais si je vous demande
d'expliquer puisque c'est vraiment et
pourquoi c'est mauvais alors non batwa
du coup on connaît la réponse je pense
la vérité c'est que le cholestérol c'est
à la fois simple et compliqué alors pour
faire simple c'est un lipide une sorte
de grèce si vous voulez qu'ils se
trouvent dans notre organisme
une partie vient de notre alimentation
mais la majorité est produite par notre
corps par notre foi en l'occurrence
eh ouais alors vous allez me dire
pourquoi une fois il fabriqué un truc
est mauvais pour la santé il est cool
quoi bah ouais il est cool quoi
rothen par les meilleurs l'asticot la
non allez fois les commandes se calme le
truc c'est que le cholestérol
c'est utile très utilement son job le
plus important c'est d'être un composant
de la membrane de nos cellules et même
de certains tissus de notre cerveau et
il aide aussi à fabriquer certaines
hormones n'est pas rien c'est peu de
chose mais le cholestérol
c'est comme toutes les bonnes choses
quand il y en a trop ça devient mauvais
et c'est là où ça se complique pas ce
qu'on entend dire tout et n'importe quoi
donc ce que je vous propose c'est de
faire le tour de la question en
démontant 5 bullshit sur le cholestérol
alors non le cholestérol oui c'est du
gras si on veut mais c'est pas le genre
de gras qui se contentent de squatter
sur vos fesses et sur vos poignées
d'amour le cholestérol lui s'accroche à
l'intérieur de vos artères sa forme ce
qu'on appelle des plaques d'athérome
hees a rétréci progressivement le
diamètre des artères qui fait le sens
ils passent de moins
- bien vous savez un peu comme dans des
tuyaux encrassé donc vos organes ils
sont le moins bien irrigué le truc c'est
que ça se forme petit à petit sans qu'on
s'en rende compte
et en plus la plaque d'athérome alors un
autre défaut c'est qu'elle est fragile
et à peu se montre comme ça sans
prévenir alors vous dit peut-être se
casse tant mieux bon débarras
bah non parce que quand elles seront il
ya des caillots qui doublent de sang
coagulé qui se forme et qui sont
libérées dans la circulation sanguine et
ils peuvent aller complètement bouché
une artère plus petites ou très rétrécit
si sa bouche une des artères qui
irriguent le coeur des coronaires
infarctus du myocarde voir arrêt
cardiaque
et si sa bouche une artère qui irriguent
le cerveau paf avc accident vasculaire
cérébral
on en a déjà parlé dans une vidéo
précédent et tout ça ça arrive de façon
brutale sans concentre le truc arrivées
dont vous voyez on parle pas juste de
prise de poids - manic alors oui mais
non en fait le cholestérol c'est du
cholestérol bon disons que le
cholestérol c'est un matériau de
construction pour les cellules et qu'il
faut quelque chose pour le transporter
jusqu'au chantier ce moyen de transport
c'est des protéines on les appelle des
lipoprotéines et y en a de deux sortes
les lipoprotéines de faible densité ldl
qui transporte le cholestérol jusqu'aux
organes et les lipoprotéines de haute
densité hdl qui ramène le surplus de
cholestérol jusqu'au x pour qu'ils
soient éliminés
donc ce qu'on appelle mauvais
cholestérol c'est le cholestérol
quellier au ldl parce que si on a
beaucoup ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de cholestérol qui circulent dont
beaucoup qui se dépose dans les artères
est ce qu'on appelle bon cholestérol
c'est celui qui est lié au hd elles qui
permettent d'éliminer le trop plein mais
en réalité le cholestérol il y en a
qu'un il a des effets positifs en
quantité normale et des effets négatifs
quand il y en a trop passons maintenant
à des médicaments qui font ça ok c'est
vrai il ya des traitements mais il faut
considérer que c'est une aide
complémentaire pour réguler son
cholestérol
en plus du régime alimentaire et de
l'hygiène de vie c'est toujours mieux
d'attaquer le problème à la racine
donc ça veut dire en priorité diminuer
les graisses saturées dans
l'alimentation c'est à dire
essentiellement les graisses d'origine
animale et augmenter les produits de
gym végétale fruits légumes céréales
sans oublier l'activité physique alors
pas la peine de courir trois marathons
par semaine 1 une demi heure de marche
par jour
c'est déjà pas mal j'ai pas de problème
de poids ne concerne pas l'annoncé pas
si simple le surpoids
c'est un indice ok mais le seul moyen
d'être sûr qu'on a pas un excès de
cholestérol c'est de faire une
surveillance médicale
ouais parce que le cholestérol et les
lipoprotéines qu'il transporte
vous savez ldl et hdl on peut savoir
combien on en a en faisant une prise de
sang est en convient on regarde aussi
les autres graisses genre les
triglycérides
ça s'appelle un bilan lipidique alors
quand est ce qu'il faut en faire un eh
ben ça c'est votre médecin qui le
détermine en fonction de votre âge vos
antécédents vos facteurs de risque etc
oui bon je suis jeune plus tard on peut
avoir un excès de cholestérol
quel que soit l'âge qu'on a parfois même
dès l'enfance si on a une maladie
héréditaire mais même en dehors de ce
genre de cas on sait qu'en france un
adulte sur cinq a trop de cholestérol et
comment on s'en rend pas compte parce
que les artères à se bougent
progressivement sans qu'il y ait de
signes pendant plusieurs années
là il faut vérifier puis surveiller si
besoin
avant que le mal soit fait donc des 18
ans c'est une bonne idée de faire un
bilan lipidique et d'en refaire ensuite
tout au long de sa vie ça peut être tous
les cinq ans ou plus fréquemment mais ça
encore une fois c'est votre médecin qui
déterminera en fonction de votre cas
vous avez compris le problème avec le
cholestérol c'est qu'ils augmentent le
risque de maladies cardiovasculaires
comme l'infarctus du myocarde ou les
accidents vasculaires cérébraux
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
estime qu'elles sont responsables de
17,7 millions de morts chaque année dans
le monde
c'est à dire presque un tiers de la
mortalité totale
alors bien sûr le cholestérol c'est pas
le seul responsable il ya aussi d'autres
trucs qui augmente le risque de
développer ce genre de maladie
l'hypertension
c'est pour ça qu'on ne recommande pas
manger trop salé le diabète
pareil avec le sucre mais il ya aussi
d'autres facteurs de risque ont rien à
voir avec ce qu'on mange comme le tabac
l'alcool
le manque d'activité physique mais aussi
le stress l'âge les antécédents
familiaux
donc vous voyez des trucs contre
lesquelles on peut rien faire mais il y
en a aussi pas mal sur lesquels on peut
agir si on veut dit
mais le risque d'être malade de dégrader
sa qualité de vie voire de mourir
brutalement sans rien voir venir
ça vaut le coup d'y penser si vous
voulez vous faire une idée
dans le cadre de la campagne le
cholestérol prenons le hacker vous
pouvez tester votre profil de risque
d'excès de cholestérol sur le site
prenons le hacker point fr je vous
remets le lien dans la description voit
la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]